Hàng in người dân dây man đã tập trung bử tình tại Thủ Rô Sana ngày 20 năm tháng bầy,
nhằm lên án đảng nói tại gà ra mà họ cho là hệ quả trực tiếp của lãnh phong tò kéo dài,
rồi is ran áp đất.
Năm đồng dương cao các biểu ước kêu gọi dưới bò phong tòa và chấm dứt chính trành,
trong bối cảnh số nạn nhân thiệt mạo vì đói, đặc biệt là trẻ em, ngày 1 tăng.
Cô bử tình tại dây man phà nếng sự cộng hưởng sâu sắc từ một khu vật cũng chữ yêu tổn thất bầy chính trành.
Trong đó người dân không chỉ đông cảm mà còn có gà ra là hình hạnh phản chíu của chính họ.
Theo cơ quan y tế gà ra,
Isran á hạnh chế viện trở nhân đạo vào gà ra trong nhiều tháng,
người ra nạn nói hàng lạc, khiến 1 trăm 20 năm hành gầy palestine, truyếu là trẻ em.
Chọc khi đó, lực lượng hầu thì, nhóm uống trang kiểm soát miệng bắt y mẹn,
tiếp tục các động thái quân sự nhằm về sự ephoi Isran.
Dịt bế này, là lấy kêng bảo về mùi cơ lăn trọng của khuôn phản biến đạo,
vừa khỏi phạm viên một cuộc xung đột đất lạc.